hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about literacy dyslexia and
compare it to my struggle to learn the
Arabic writing system now this all
started when someone asks I think on
Facebook how I went about learning the
Arabic writing system now there are
various systems out there but all I did
essentially was to download a list of
the Arabic letters in all their four
forms for each letter and slowly start
to read using our lessons that link the
big advantage at link is that we can
actually sound i as a user it can sound
out each word or even a phrase or a
sentence or whatever so as I read if I
look at the word and I try to piece
together what letters they are and very
often I get it wrong I can hear it and
so be by doing that and continuing to do
that and at the same time because that
link in our five activities one of them
is dictation I can then hear a word and
attempt to write it and immediately see
if I got it right or wrong
using the Arabic keyboard that I have on
my iPad so just by continuing to do this
my brain gradually got more and more
used to the Arabic writing system when I
read stories that linked our many
stories I tend to do it in the sentence
mode and you can find the sentence mode
on the web site by adjusting there is a
setting there and you can have one
sentence show up or the whole you know I
think it's called page size or something
but you can see very clearly in the
settings that there is a place where you
can set it to sentence mode mostly I
study on my mobile device there we have
sentence mode in the sort of beta
version that I'm using it will soon be
available to all users but on the web
site and you can you can access the web
site from your mobile device as well
there you can use
sentence mode so with sentence mode I'm
dealing with a small chunk of of Arabic
writing at a time I can listen text to
speech to the whole sentence I can
listen to the individual word so you
know I read it I'm not confident that I
read it correctly and so I can hear it
now why does all this matter it matters
because in Arabic it's not obvious it's
not always obvious from the letters that
are there even if you actually
identified the letters correctly which
you know I don't always do yet but I'm
getting pretty close to being there but
you don't know what the vowel sounds are
in many cases and so I find that with
Arabic you know until I know the word I
don't really know how it's pronounced I
can't just tell by reading it which we
can do in Spanish for example which it's
not quite as easy to do in English but
in Arabic is even more difficult so now
there are sounds in Arabic that
represent vowels there are these little
diacritics and stuff like that I tend to
ignore them you know maybe I'm wrong but
that's to me it's just clutter because
apparently when I eventually do start
reading Arabic or look at our besides if
I'm visiting an Arabic country these
little phonetic markers are often not
used so really if the only purpose of
these is to enable me to decipher these
words then I just assume rely on the
audio and I can rely not only on the
text-to-speech which is sometimes not
accurate but I can also hear the natural
voice say these sentences as I go
through these sentences so I might try
to read it once without any help then I
listen to the text to speech and then I
listen to the natural voice so
essentially I slowly slowly get used to
the writing system I find that if I pick
up a book where I can't interact with
the
texts I can't hear the touch to speech
or the natural voice it's more difficult
however words that I have already
listened to while reading in link or
because I listened these stories 30 40
times that I've heard these words so
many times that I know the word I know
what the word sounds like and therefore
I'm able to read it so really I only I
can only read what I've already seen
before so I was thinking about all of
this
and I'm saying you know I'm sort of in
the position of someone who has severe
reading problems who has a low level of
literacy or possibly is dyslexic who
can't make out what the letters are
supposed to read like and you know a lot
of people suffer from low levels of
literacy and it's important to remember
that from an evolutionary perspective
our you know ancestors the cave people
didn't read it's something relatively
recent that we have this ability to
record stuff in in writing because prior
to that people would simply have to
repeat what they heard so a story
tellers would repeat the same story
century after century nowadays we have
the ability to record it as a written
text well recently much more recently we
have the ability to record the actual
voice and of course the ability to use
these voice files has become more and
more sophisticated and so now we have
the ability if we read on a mobile
device around the computer we can
actually hear the words text-to-speech
version or I can actually you know find
that audio track from the audio track
from the the narrator and hear it so we
have an ability now to access the sort
of audio in a very you know flexible and
effective manner so how does this relate
to dyslexia and and literacy well
it has been demonstrated that you know
there are people who have trouble
listening and people have listening
difficulties typically develop reading
difficulties and this can continue
through to their adult life so in the
workplace for example that can be a big
disadvantage so I was thinking you know
maybe this idea of isolating sentences
providing the audio for that sentence
natural voice as well as providing the
individual audio for individual words
and phrases and and encouraging these
people have trouble reading to use audio
in order to get used to the words
because if if essentially in my case in
Arabic when I do start reading
essentially I I believe that I'm only
going to be able to read words that I've
already heard and that I will guess at
the pronunciation and meaning of other
words or look them up but essentially I
will be dealing with words that I have
heard so if a person who struggles with
reading and has dyslexia has a strategy
of doing so much listening that they
will develop a vast vocabulary of words
that they have heard and heard more than
once so that as they encounter words
they're not forced to decipher the
pronunciation letter-by-letter which is
in a way in a sense my strategy with
Arabic I I'm able to decipher the
pronunciation letter-by-letter because
of the inconsistencies in in the Arab
writing system but if my strategy is to
do so much listening and acquire this
vast vocabulary of words that I have
heard and which therefore I recognized
then my reading is going to improve so
the question is I wonder if what I'm
going through someone learning the
Arabic alphabet and learning to read in
Arabic in any way is similar to the
struggles of someone who has trouble
deciphering letters spelling has trouble
and whether there aren't some solutions
there because literacy is an enormous
you know has an enormous economic and
therefore social cost so there you have
it just the thought on the application
of my experience learning Arabic and
some of the functionality at linked to a
larger societal problem and that is
literacy and the various reading
disabilities that people have all right
I look forward to your comments thank
you for listening bye for now
[Music]